[音楽]先月の話の2部と指摘をお話しさせていただきます
先月はごく普通の一般的にこの知識っていうのはどういうふうに獲得できますか？という
全くそんなに仏教だけの話ではなくて
普通に心の話でしたと思います
で どのように我々人間が知識を獲得するべきかという
いろいろ勉強方法とか記憶力
記憶力ですか いろんなものを記憶する方法とか
そこら辺いくらかは話しましたけど
その話も途中で時間なくなって終わりましたけど
全部話すわけではないんです
まあ今日はそこをそれで終わってしまって
で 知恵という知識と知恵というテーマですから
今日はなんとか知恵の話をしてみましょうと
で どう違いますかね 知識と知恵は
で どう違いますかね？やっぱりそこら辺
ちょっと言葉に操れないで新しく考えないと理解できないかもしれません
でまあ一応私は自分なりに定義をいたしますが
知識っていうのは勉強と同じもので
言葉の世界なんですね
で 概念の世界 頭の中でいろんな概念
言葉を通して 積み込む
それは知識というんですね
で まあそういうものでよって
我々はまあいろいろ元気で生きてるんですね
知識があるんだから生きてると
で 我々は子供たちに学校に行かせて何をしてほしいかというと
知識は思い存分思い存分頭の中にいっぱい詰まってほしいんですね
性格は気にしない 性格はどうでもいいんです
知識さえあれば ということで
まあ教育 教育は完全に
まあ現代教育っていうのは知識の世界
いわゆる頭の中にいろんな概念
いろんな言葉 まあ言葉たくさんないんですけど
いろんな言葉もあっちこっち回したりして振り回したりして
またいろいろ頭に積み込んであげる
それからそれはいろいろ試験とか面接とか
そういうところで まあどれぐらい知識が固まっているかどうかね
調べて この人はいいやと
この人はいいやと まあ入学させたり
会社に入社させたりはする
そこまでいいんだけど
せっかく入学したんだけど
ろくな学生生活できない人もいるし
入社はしたんだけど 会社のためには何の役にも立たない
ただ生ゴミだけの人間もいるんですね
まあ生きてる それで困ったなとか
ああだこうだと また知識を積み重ね積み込めようと思っちゃうんですね
それどう違いますかと
同じ学校を出ても 同じ教育を受けても
それぞれ人間 また違うところはあるんですね
ある人は役に立つし ある人は全く役に立たない
そこら辺から知恵の世界始まるんです
ですから 知識は言葉の集まりであるならば
そこに論理というものがありますね
その論理も正しい論理じゃなくて
人間の勝手な論理なんです
ですから 世の中にある倫理論理というのは
そんな大したことないんです
全部好き勝手にいい加減なものしかないんです
ある時期はこれはやってはいけない
あれはやってはいけないとものすごく言って
もう大変怒られたりするし
ちょっと年  5年  6年経つと
まあそんなことはどうでもいいやと違うことをやってはいけないと言ったりするし
もうそれにも何の根拠も何もないんですね
例えば論理にしたっても
まあ今日ちょっと頭に浮かんだことなんですけど
中国の指導者ですか もう死んじゃって
死んじゃって言ったら失礼ですかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの まあ 亡くなりまして
で それそれについていろいろ番組があって
そこでこの日本側の反論
反論ではなくて考え方出ていますけど
まあこの何て言いますか
計画してね 管理して 計画的な経済システムを解放して
自由経済を導入した人だから
もう大変素晴らしいことをした人ですよと
それだけ褒めてるんですね
いわゆる他の人々に商売できるようにしてくれたんだから
もう素晴らしい人だと
その人にはそれしか得がないみたいんですね
だからすごい賢そうに喋るんだけど
何？ただ自分勝手に喋ってるだけではないかと
でもただそういうだけで
私その時これなんです
感じたのは  市場経済ということは
自由経済ということは
その自由経済の国にはすごくありがたい
ありがたい それこそ真実だと言うんだけど
その国の経済状態が重要になって
一番悪知恵がある人々は思い存分儲かってくださいと
弱い者は死んでしまえというシステムでしょう
とにかくは その なんて言いますか
そのいいところだけ見て
悪いところは全く無視
無関心で経済学やら論理を喋ってるんですね
それはその人々にとってはすごい正しい知識的な話なんですけど
どんな経済にも興味ない人が第三者の立場で見ると
なんかちょっとおかしいんですね
そこでまた じゃあその人
中国のリーダーが中国の問題を全部解決したんですか？と
それ全くなくて 市場経済状態が出てきたんだから
もうかなり中国ではもう社会状態が崩れちゃって
いろいろ問題がありまして
とんでもない金持ちが出てきて
もうもうご飯も食べられないほどものすごい貧しい人々が出てきたりとか
それでも政府にはもうお金がないんだから
どうしようもなくて あんた方は勝手にしなさいという感じになっちゃって
もう生きるか死ぬかぐらいのきつい状態に生きてる
中国地方もあるんです
そこでマフィアみたいに暴力団が出てくるは
日本にありとあらゆる密告ですか
組織が出てくるはもう問題だらけなんですね
前はそれほどなかったんだけど
ですから 人間というのは勝手にまあ市場経済こそありがたいと言うんだけど
そうじゃなくて そちらにもあの
いいところも悪いところもあります
その両方考えて喋るならば
いくらかの合理なんですけど
そうは絶対ないんだ 世の中では
自分好きなものは万々歳と応援するだけで
嫌いなものはもう絶対的に嫌い
嫌い 嫌い 悪人だと決めてるだけで
そういう世界で人間ずっと生きてくるんだから
まあその論理 論理 理論
そういう理論なんですけど
やっぱり我々の知識の世界っていうのはそういう世界なんですね
例えば医者に聞けば 風邪引いてきました
じゃあ手術しましょうと
風邪にでもできれば手術したいんでね
医者が それになんか文句言っちゃったら
あんた方何知ってるんですかと
冗談じゃないとまた怒られるんですね
で がんになったら自分で決めます
それは患者さんに決められます
医者が決めるもんだと
で 偉そうなことを言ったりするんですね
やっぱり自分勝手なんですね
この知識の世界 知識の世界っていうのは
ちゃんと具体的に物事を見て
バランスを取って判断しようとはしない
医者は医者の勝手で判断する
弁護士は弁護士の勝手で
その角度で物事を判断すると
政治家は自分勝手で で
両側の立場 いろんな多側面から物事を見ようとはしない
ですから 知識っていうのは
みんないっぺんにありがたい
ありがたい ありがたいと思う
そんなに一言では言えるもんじゃないんです
じゃあ知識はいけませんか？と
それも言えますと とんでもない話で
ですから このまあ 知識の世界はそういう世界で
まず言葉の世界 概念の世界で
それから論理ですか？ロジックですか
一つのロジカルみたいな
まあロジック世界なんですけど
僕ら仏教からはそれはシュドロジックというんですね
偽掛けのロジックだと
全然論理じゃないんです
それは仏教から見れば
論理はもう全く成り立ってないんだけど
でも一般の方々にとっては
自分たちはしっかりした合理的な人間だと
その風に思って生きてはいるんですね
例えば長生きしなくちゃとかね
今日ある人から電話かけてきて
もう何一つも希望通りにいかないんですよ
この頃と言って ものすごい腹が立ってるんですね
私も腹が立ったんですね
全部自分の希望通りに行ってほしいと思う
バカもいいバカもんなんですね
それぐらい屁理屈なんですね
ちょっと考えてみてください
私たちの希望通りに世の中が動いちゃったら
1週間で終わりですよ
この地球も全部 それぐらい人間というのは汚くて恐ろしくて
あいつは憎いと思っちゃったら
すぐその人をやっつけて殺してしまいたいでしょうに
あれ欲しいと思ったら
欲しいものはすぐ自分のものにしたいでしょうに
お金があったらお金いくらあってももうキリがないでしょうに
それで欲しい欲しいと思った
ある人がすごい金持ちになると思っちゃったら
世界中のお金をその人のところに集めちゃったらどうなるんですかね
世界は やっとこんなに恐ろしい世界なのに
たった一つ救いがあるのは
何一つも人間の希望通りにいかないことなんです
もし間違ってでも人間の希望通りに行ったならば
大変なことになるんです
そこを合理的に考えない
自分の心に聞かない 私の希望って何ですか？と
それで私の希望通り何でもかんでも言ってくださいとと頼んでみたら
まあ恐ろしくてしょうがないんですね
ですから 世の中っていうのは希望通りにいかないのは当たり前で
それ嫌というのは合理的ですかね
希望通りにいかないのは嫌ですよと
私は元気で頑張って 物事を自分の希望通りにしますと
その人々はすごい元気だという
よく頑張る人だという
ちゃんとした合理的な人間だという
世界は言うんだけど でもあれは合理的ですね
物事は自分の希望通りにいくんですかね
いかないでしょうね 何一つも
それなのにそう言ってほしい
人は死にたくないでしょ
希望通りにいえば死ななかったらどうなるんですかね
もし昔の人々は希望通りにいて死ななかったなら
我々今ここにないでしょうに
なんか蜂の巣の蜂のようにいっぱい人
人 人だけいるんであって
そこで生活できないでしょ
蜂にもものすごい巨大な領域が必要なんですよ
蜂蜜を採るために 花から蜜を吸うために
人間よりものすごい土地が必要なんですよ
小さな蜂に それで人間死ななかったらどうなるんですかね
年取っても死なないと
例えばなんか自動電車なんかに飛び込んでも
むちゃくちゃにぺっちゃんこになっても
それでも死なないんだと
面白いですかね だからまあ
それでも死にたくないと
年は取りたくないんだとよく言うもんですね
それで薬も作る 不老長寿とかね
長生きできるようにとか
健康 人間の健康を守るためにとかね
じゃあ見てください ずっと科学的に研究して
研究しても もう医者であろうが誰も知らないほどの薬の種類があるでしょうに
じゃあ何か助かったこと一つもありますかね
結局 人間昔も同じく病気になるんであって
お医者さんはいつでもお手上げ状態で
人がなんとか縁がいい
なんて言いますか なんかラッキーで病気が治った方が治るか
あるいはそうでなくなって死ぬか
どっちかなんですね 結局
いまだに我々は薬を飲んで健康的になるかならないかっていうのは
体の勝手であって 科学のおかげではないんですね
どんな素晴らしい薬であろうが
もう体それ否定しちゃったらもう何の意味もないし
まあまあ そういうふうな世界で
この論理はあるんだけど
まあ論理っていうのはなんかものすごいいい加減で
ちょっと考えちゃったらおかしいんですね
ですから 僕らの話も聞いて
なんかこの人の話でも聞いて
自分の希望通りに物事を言ってくれるんじゃないかなとかね
長生きできるんじゃないかなと
病気治してくれるんじゃないかなと思ったりして仏教を聞くんだけど
そういう約束をしてね
人を騙すことはいとも簡単にできますけどね
でも事実は逆なんですね
そうなっちゃったら ものすごい地獄そのものになるんですね
希望通りのことを言ったら
それはそれで置いておいて
論理の世界 言葉の世界は知識の世界
それから知識っていうのは
物事の一部だけ勉強する
物事は全部勉強しようとはしないのは知識の世界なんです
何か一つ知って それで食べているんですね
全てを知っちゃったら困るんです
知識の世界では 医者は患者さんのことを機械みたいに扱って
いらないものを切って捨てて
抜いてなんとかして もうはい
終わりましたと そこで患者が治ろうか
それからもうもうどんなひどい目に遭うか
それは別にお医者さんの仕事ではないんですね
一応癌だから癌を取り出しましたと
それからどうやって生きてるんですか？それは知らないんだ
そんなことは 胃も腸も全部取り出しましたと
ったらもう食べられないでしょ
まあそれだったらもう何か管でも入れて栄養をあげますと
それで栄養あげたところで
何か体の他のところはおかしくなったな
それだったらそこら辺またいじりますと
そういうふうなことで
まあこれで人間ですかとかね
ここまでして生きていきたいんですか？とか
例えば腸も捨てて胃も捨てて
もう肺もなんだかんでも捨てて
もうただもうなんとかベッドの上の肉の塊になって
でも長生きするべきですかとかね
そこら辺お医者さんは考えてはいけないことで
考えないことで 知識っていうのはそういうもので
考えちゃったら仕事ができなくなっちゃうんですね
お医者さんにも 足を切断しなくちゃいけないのは
もう何のことなく平気で足を切断して捨てると
これから人生どうなる？それは別に気にしない
だからといってお医者さんに悪口を言うことはできないし
なぜならそれ知識の世界だから
自分の分野しかもう考えません
弁護士も同じでしょうに
どんな犯罪者であろうか
弁護士はもう弁論するでしょ
そこで上手な弁護士だったら
その人は無罪にすることですよ
結局は 自分が弁論する人たちはみんな有罪になるんだったら
いい弁護士にはなりっこはないんだから
あの弁護士を頼んだら
お金も高いだけではなくて
必ず裁判に負けるんだというならば
もう弁護士じゃないでしょ
ですから 弁護士の仕事っていうのは
犯罪者を 逃がしてあげることなんです
そこを真面目に考えちゃったら
弁護士にはなりたくはなくなっちゃうんですね
だからとんでもない犯罪者と同じ悪いことをするのは弁護士の仕事だから
もっと悪いのは法律で守られてるんだから
弁護士が弁護士を そこまで考えちゃったら弁護士になりたくはないんです
ですから まあとにかくまあ弁護しますと
人々を助けてあげますと
いわゆるいろいろ裁判抱えたりして
いろんなことで悩んで
で まあどうしようもない
法律はわかりませんだから
ですから 私は法律の専門家になって
そういう法律の助けを必要な人々を助けてあげますというふうに自分に言い返しちゃって
世の中にそういう法律というローヤル法という仕事があるんです
だから 本当にあれで人を助けられているかないかっていうのはまた別な話で
だからそこまで考える必要はないんですね
知識の世界では 政治の世界は
政治家は自分がどうすれば自分の権力を野党側に奪われないかということだけ考えて行動するんです
もし政治家が国のために
国民のために行動したら
すぐその政府はもう倒れちゃうんです
それはもう歴史的な事実なんです
正直なものには政治できないんです
政治を取ったら 必死で権力を守ることに必死で苦労しなくちゃいけない
それは昔からもうこの地球にある事実なんです
でも 一般の人々を守るために政治をやっている
例えば 今の風に言えば
何て言いますか あの消費税はね ５
パーセント上げて それで国民のために
国民の希望通りにやってるんだそうですけどね
で またそれ据え置きにするんだそうですね ５
パーセントは それ すごいいいことしてるように喋るんですね
大きな音で３パーセントの消費税はね ５
パーセントにして それまたそれでちょっとまあ来年はそれ以上上がらないで待ってるんだと
この待ってることにすごく威張ってるんだから
まあ自分が５パーセントにしたことには何も言わないとか
まあまあそんな理屈ではもうできないんで
とにかく私が言う理屈では
政治も弁護士も何一つ成り立たないんですね
もし私言うことを真面目に聞いちゃったら
もう何もできなくなっちゃうんです
政治もできなくなっちゃうし
医者の仕事もできなくなっちゃうし
で 私はこの仏教の立場で言うんであって
社会の知識人の立場っていうのは
物事を一つの側面でだけ見て行動しろと
それからどうなるか それからどうなるかという
もう全部考えちゃうと
もう何もできなくなるんです
例えば タバコ会社が作ったんだと
それだったらどうすればいいんですか？片っ端からタバコを売るしかないでしょうに
すごい まあ投資してタバコ会社作ったならば
もうありとあらゆる宣伝しなくちゃいけない
だからまあそれもタバコはまあとても体にいいことだよと言えませんだから全部宣伝に嘘を言わなくちゃいけない
美しい風景とか スイスの風景とか
大変魅力のある馬の写真とか
すごい美しい美人並んだりとかね
有名な人々を出したりとか
そこでユーイスピークラーと言うんですね
で それ何言ってるんですか？あの宣伝で何も言ってないんです
でも そういう宣伝によってタバコを買ったりする
もしタバコの会社の社長が本当にタバコっていうのはこんな売りまくっていいんですか？とか
これでがんになるんだから
自分でがんセンターでも作ってやろうと
利益でタバコを吸った人々はがんになっちゃったら
私のがんセンターに来ればもう半額で治療してあげましょうと言っちゃうと
まあよく考えると親切な行為なんですけど
それだったらその会社のタバコは誰も吸わないんです
ですから そういうものには大反対する
お金も出せない 援助もしない
そういう会社は できればスポーツとか音楽系統とか芸術系統とか
そこら辺にいくらかお金をあげたりする
で そういう風になってるんですね
もしタバコ会社の社長が真面目に合理的に考えちゃったら
もう仕事できなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 自分の目 自分の立場だけを見て計算して
どんな俳優さん にコマーシャルを頼めば売れるかと
ですから どんな人が人気ありますかとかね
それは自分が買って そういうふうにコマーシャルして
まあとにかく売ると それだけの世界なんですね
学者の世界も同じ 歴史学者は歴史ばっかし語っていて
他の学問とは何の連絡もないんです
考古学者は穴掘るだけでも
現代人にとっては別に何も役に立つことはしない
穴を掘って穴を掘って
何かまあまあ 壺のかけらとか何とか見つかっちゃって
それまたあの 何といいますか
大体 1000年ぐらい古いというふうに感じだったら
必ず 1500年か 2000年にするんです
聞いてみれば まあそうでないとなんとかないんだと
何でしたっけ あれはロマンスがないんだと
それで僕らはえらい考古学者だと褒めているんですね
やっぱりそれぐらいのことなんですね
僕は信じません この 3000年のなんとかなんとか 2000年のなんとかなんとかと
全部信じないわけじゃないんだけど
きちんとした研究結果だったら
まああの 土の あの 何て言いますか
このレイヤースありますから
そのレイヤースからちゃんと掘ってきて
このレイヤーは何年か
このレイヤーは何年かと
ちゃんとこのカーボン研究といろいろありますね
それから出てきた結果だったら
いくらかそうだろうと
でもぴったし日にち言うことはできませんだけど
でもたまにこの学者の間で議論があるんですね
これは 1500年古い
ある人は いえ  2300年古い
あるいは 3000年古いだという場合は
みんな自分のロマンスを語っているだけなんです
まあとにかく だからといって
考古学者の世界はそういう何か壺の欠片とかね
まあ何か古い人々のゴミ箱とかね
そういうものがやっぱり縄文人のゴミ箱ですね
あれ 発見発掘しているのは
そこら辺から人の性格をなんとか考えてみようとか
で 楽しく遊んでるんですね
それによって何か社会に貢献するものとかね
だから現代生きてる我々の生活は何か役に立ったということはないんです
そこら辺まで考えちゃうと
あの仕事できなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから もし仏教的な考え方が入っちゃったら
とんでもないことになっちゃう
もう何一つもできなくなるんです
っていう ですから 私が申し上げたいのは
この知識世界っていうのは論理的論理はあるんだけど
全部この完全たるすべてのものを把握して出来上がっている論理ではないんです
その自分の分野をどう成立するかということしか考えない
この弁護士の方々のやり方は私は知ってますけど
例えばこの誰かの弁護をする場合は
自分たちの証人出しちゃうんですね
警察側からではなくて
いい この人は無罪ですよというために
たまに反対の証人も出す場合あるんですね
そのテクはたまにこの証人作るんですね
これぐらい誰かが言ってくれれば
これOKやというふうな法律上ありますね
証人も作っちゃうんです
あんたはこういうふうに
こういうふうに答えなさいと
で それから自分たちで研究を探したところで
本当にこの自分が弁護をしようとすると
本当に犯人だと自分で証拠を見つかっちゃう
でも 自分が見つかった証拠は警察は見つかってないんです
その場合は弁護士さんがどうすると思います？警察側に上げますか？こういう証拠がありますから
それを使ってちゃんとあなた方は訴えてくださいと
私はもう被告人のために弁護しますよということにならないんです
あの証拠を全部隠すんです
たとえ弁護士であろうとも
証拠を隠すことも犯罪なんです
でも隠す 確実に そう隠さなきゃ自分の仕事できないでしょうに
自分が無罪ですよということを言わなくちゃいけない
だって 自分そろった証拠の中では有罪というふうに言える証拠はない
いっぱいあるならば それは全部なんとかもう表に出ないようにと
そういう世界で我々は生きて食べてるんですね
ですから 仏教から見れば
みんな不費 何て言いますか
法に乗って食べてるわけじゃないんです
法を犯して生活してるんです
法っていうのは この普遍的な法則なんですね
だからいろいろ不幸なこともありますよ
だから競争もあるし 倒産もするし
それはまあしょうがない
じゃあ そこまでは知識の世界
ちょっと知識に文句言わなきゃ
知恵の世界はわからなくなりますから
で 仏教にも知識の世界がありまして
論理の世界があります
仏教の知識っていうのは
ほとんどごく普通の科学的な知識はそのまま認めるし
論理の場合はまあちょっと違うんですね
理論作っても使ってもいいんだけど
ただ一方的に使うなと
できるだけ人々を生命の幸福を
より多くの人々の幸福にならないと
その知識は捨てなさいと
その論理も捨てろと という立場で
いわゆる道徳論はもう重ね合わせているんですね
論理が倫理と一緒でなければいけません
倫理も論理も一つになってなければいけないんですね
例えば 人にお金をあげるのはいいことではいいことですよかと言ったら
一般の人はものすごい無責任に無責任でいいことでしょう
別にという思っちゃうかもしれません
仏教はそういうふうに無責任には言わないんです
もしその人をお金をもらって
自分も幸福になって より大勢の人々の幸福を作る人であるならば
それはいいことであって
その人お金もらって それで何か鉄砲でも買っちゃって
麻薬でも買って それを使うならば
あれは道徳ではなくて犯罪行為ですと
単なるじゃあ人に 1010万円あげることは正しいことですか？悪いことですかと言えば
そういうふうに判断するんです
ある人に10万円あげるのは大変いいことで
素晴らしいことであって
ある人に10万円あげたらあなたは犯罪者ですよと
でも 人の行動は 結局自分が10万円あげちゃってロスしただけなんですけど
あげたんだからといって得というわけじゃないんですね
ですから この仏教の倫理
論理はいつでも倫理に一緒なんですね
普通の社会の論理は倫理と関係ない
倫理っていうのは迷惑なんですね
学校でも倫理っていうのは誰も気にしない
教えたくはない 子供たちも勉強したくない科目なんですね
すごい迷惑なんです でも倫理なくなっちゃったら
誰にでも生きていられないんです
全部一発でなくなっちゃうんです
我々は道徳を守るんだから平和でいるんです
それでもみんな道徳っていうのは面倒くさいんだと
法律を守ることも面倒くさいんだと
だからなんとかしてごまかそう
ごまかそうと 会社っていうのは
もし法律で厳しく罰せられない場合は
そんなに社員に給料は払いたくないんですよ
社員は残業してくれるくれて
でも残業手当もらわないんだったらすごくありがたがるんです
でもありがとうとは言わない
行っちゃったら即ボコされるんだから当たり前だというの
その場合でも それでも産業手当を上げなくちゃいけない
なぜならば法律で決まってるんだから
それ ありがたくくれてるわけじゃないんです
嫌でくれてるんです 給料さえ
まあ大体まあそれまあ僕は規則言うだけで
まあどこでもやっぱり法律
道徳っていうのは生活する上では邪魔になっているとみんな思ってるんです
正しく生きることはよく邪魔ですよと
で それまたどれほど屁理屈かというと
もし社会から道徳が消えちゃったら
そこでもう社会システムは終了終わり
ただの野蛮の世界 お互いに殺しやっちゃって終わるんです
ですから 今 現代のこの発展
見せかけの発展も もうすべて科学的な発展も
何であろうとも 人間がいくらかでも道徳的に生きているんだから
あるんで 存在しているんであって
道徳が消えちゃったら終わりと
例えば外人だったら アメリカのいろんな
いろんなあっちこっちあるように
外人だったら殺されるかだいぶ生きてうちに帰れるかわからないんだと思っちゃったら
どうやって生きてればいいんですかね
我々の人生は蚊と同じくなっちゃうんですね
蚊はもう仕事に出る場合は奥さんに言うんだそうですね
まあこれから仕事に行きますよと
それも面白い話で 別に小さいのはメスだけですけど
もしパチンと音を聞いたら諦めてくださいと
で そんな感じでになるでしょ
私たちも もし人間が道徳回らなかったら
それなのにみんな道徳だけは嫌なんですね
学校でもそれはあまり大事な科目じゃないんです
高校試験ではそれ全然聞かない
大学入学試験には全く縁のない話なんですね
入社試験にも縁のない話なんでしょ
結局は よくも人間屁理屈使うなと僕は思いますよ
あれこそ大事なのに どれくらい人は正直かとか
どれぐらい約束を守れる人か
どれぐらい責任持てるものかと
そこ一番大事なんです
ですから 人々は色々工夫して
その人のこのもうエシカルフレームワークという
この道徳的にどんな精神的な
どんな工夫の人ができているんですかと
調べた方がいいのに そこはもういらない
スポーツはどれぐらいやったんですか？とか
そればっかり聞くんです
だからサッカーよくできるんだからって
コンピューターソフトウェア会社にね
就職したっても あれ コンピューター足で蹴ってプログラム作るんですかね
やっぱりそういうものを聞くんですね
よくも だから私はそういうとんでもない理屈で
もう何回も面接をダメになった覚えがあるんです
いろんな面接に行って
そんなくだらない質問するんです
僕はそんな質問を聞いて
あなたは はどうなる？どうなるんですかと
また返って質問したんですね
そしたら怒られて 私たちは面接やってるんだけど
あなたは言うことに答えなさいと
そうしたら私はそれを答えますけど
これ なんでこんなくだらない質問するんです？私も疑問があるんですと
私はこういうこういうことの仕事のために面接を受けてるんだから
私が知ってる限りはその仕事をできるんだから出したんでしょうと
で 私が知ってる限りは
そんな質問なんか そんな内容全く関係ないんだと
で そこでまあもう知識的な喧嘩になっちゃって
まあそれでまあもういろいろ話やったんだけど
結局私はもうパスと全く資格のない人を選んじゃったんです
選んでも仕事はできない
それから頼んで私にお願いしますから
来てくださいと で 頼んで仕事
僕は偉そうに威張っちゃっていったんです
その時も面接はあったんだけど
僕は 30 分遅れて行ったんです
それはみんなにできることではなくて
まあ私はどうでもいいっていう感じで行ったんだからいいんですけど
皆様はそんな大胆なことしてはいけませんし
でも あの ほとんど頼まれる仕事でした
若い時はね  世の中にほとんどないと思いますよ
年取ったところに頼まれて仕事を頼まれる場合ありますけど
経験を買いますからね
で まあそれは置いておいて
大体この道徳っていうのは大変大事なものなんですけど
世俗的な世界では まあそれは無視しよう
無視しよう 無視しようと
と思ってる で 仏教の知識の世界で違うところは
道徳 論理より倫理は先と倫理は土台であって
そこに論理が成り立とうんだ
成り立つんだと こう言うんですね
で 知識は生き方によって完成されるんだと
いわゆるあの知識と道徳といえば
知識の完成は道徳にあって
道徳の完成は知識にあるんだと
それ一つも離せる かけ離すことはできません
人間として これ面白いストーリーで
あるこのブラフマン人が若い人がお釈迦様に会いに行ったんです
あのボラモンの文化では
ボラモン人というのはすごい偉いんです
ボラモンの家族で生まれたら
生まれつき聖職者で 神の子で
もう他の人々にはどうすることもできない
人は生まれるとそういう家族で生まれなくちゃいけない
他のところで生まれちゃったら
もう神の子ではないんです
ですから 自分たちは神様の子供でということで威張ってるんですね
そこでこのその人はボラモン人であると
ボラモンっていうのは
いわゆる修行者という意味もあって
知識人という意味もありますで
聖聖者という意味もあるんですね
全部自分が自分のものだと思ってるんですね
父親がボラモン人だったら
自分がもう聖者なんです
それだけのことで  それは仏教で認めてないんだけど
その子に聞いたんですね
人は完全なボラモンに
ブラフマンにボラモンになるためにはどれぐらい条件必要ですかと
言ったら 彼がこう言うんですね
美しい麗しい体格と体で
いわゆるかっこいいこと
きちんと見たらすごい人やと見える
で もう一つは 7 代目まで
えーと 何て言いますか
血統 ちゃんとブラマン系統の血統はきちんとあること
3番目はヴェーダ聖典やら注釈やら歴史やらね
いろいろものを覚えて勉強していること
次には物事にすべてちゃんと判断できる知恵があること
次には それは 5番目  4番目に言ったのは
このもう道徳的にいい行いを
いい生活を 正しい生活を
悪いことをしないで 自分の口も体も守って生活すること
4番目には よく物事を理解できる知恵があること
お釈迦様はよし わかりました
この 5つは必要ですよと
その 5つの中から一つぐらいこの取り消せることはできますか？と
例えば この一つ この条件がなくても OK やと言えるものはありますか？と言ったら
あなたにできますかと考えること
と言ったら この人はできますよ
このかっこいい人で生まれると
この人の格好って別に関係ないんですと
すごいいい美男でなければという
そんなこと関係ないんだ
ですからそれはカットできますと
この 4つの条件をされていればぴったししたブラマンですと
でお釈迦様はわかりました
すごいと じゃあこの今 4つだけあればいいでしょ
この 4つから何か一つ条件なくてもまあいいという条件がないんですか？と言ったら
ありますね 考えれば この 7代まで血統は純血でなければ
そんなことどうでもいいんじゃないかと
誰が知ってるんですかと
ですから この血統っていうのは意味がないんだと
それ捨てられるんだと
で また 2つ抜けちゃったんですね
で 次に結構もう一つ何か抜け落ちたら何かないんですか？と言ったら
こんないろんなことをね
ヴェーダやら歴史やら
あんなことを勉強しなくちゃいけないと言ったっても
みんなにできるわけでもないし
あれもあんまり役に立たないんですねと
それに捨てられるんだと
結局 2つしか残らなかったんです
もう 5つ目の条件で でお釈迦様は最後に聞くんですね
この 2つの条件で何かなくてもいいという何かないんですか？と
ただ この若者は まあこれはちょっと無理ですと
知恵がないともうダメですと
人間には知恵があっても道徳なければ何の意味もないんだと
ですから 道徳的な生き方と知恵の中で一つ取れと言ったっても
それだけは取れませんと
家柄はどうであろうと
それにも関係なく ただ
お釈迦様はまさにあなたの言う通りですよ
シーラパリドーターパンジャパンジャパリドーターシーランという彼の言葉をお釈迦様は褒めてあげたんですね
ウィスダムパーフェクトモラリティモラリティパーフェクトウィスダムという道徳的な生き方によって知恵が明らかになると
知恵によって道徳的な生き方が明らかになると
その相互関係  ヒンドゥー教ではそこまで言ってなかったんだけど
お釈迦様は事実だから
強引に言わせちゃうんですね
そちらに なぜならば 合理的に喋るならば
まあ同じ答えが出ますから
そういうことで まあ仏教の違うところはやっぱりどういうところですか
論理だけ偉いというわけじゃなくて
めちゃくちゃめちゃくちゃ口先で合理口先だけで合理的に喋ってもあんまり気にしないんですね
驚かないと同時に 人はよくできて
性格は良くて 素晴らしい人間であるならば
もう信頼してもいいと
人は信頼できないんだけど
口先でだけ頭だけはすごく動いているんだと言ったら
そこはあまり信頼しないというかね
その点では仏教の違うところなんですね
ですから 僕らは一体言いたいのは
もうちょっと ちょっともうちょっと合理的になってほしいですね
社会の人々は ただ金儲けることではなくて
目的は人々のために 幸福のために
自分の生きる目的ですか
オブジェクティブライフという
この生活するこの目的は変えなくちゃいけないんです
どんな人間でも 子供でも
みんなのために生きてるんだと
みんなに何かいいことをしなくちゃいけないんだ
これは自分の仕事だと
それは大人だったら真剣に考えなくちゃいけないんですね
仕事を考える時でも 他のことを考える時でも
やっぱり人の役に立つということ
そこら辺ですね ちょっと変えてほしいと思うの
じゃあ 今はまだまだ知識のことばっかり喋ってますけど
そういうのは知識の世界で
知恵の世界っていうのはもう随分違うんです
これ 何が違いますかというと
前も言ったように 同じ大学を卒業している二人がどこかに同じ会社に入ったところで
何か差が現れてくるでしょ
どこかで 全くもう退職するまで全くぴったし同じということはないんですね
仕事をやっている間では
いろんな差が出てくる
アメリカだったらもうものすごく差が出てくる
同じ学校を出て 同じ会社に同じで入ったっても
ある人は副社長まで上るかもしれません
ある人はただ入ったまま
そのまま社員だけで残るかもしれませんし
まあ日本はそんなにきつくはないんだけど
それでも差はあることはあるんですね
どこにあるんですか？と
それは知恵の世界なんです
その差は 普段言うこの能力の世界
それは知恵の世界なんですね
もっと簡単に言えば この勉強は誰にでもできますよ
それなりの勉強 もう動物もやってますからね
猿 猿もやってるでしょ？いろんな芸なんか勉強して
もうちゃんと習ってやってるし
歌を歌うオウムもいるし
ちゃんとした日本語の歌とかね
もうそれなりに まあ発音がちょっとなまってますけどね
大ナマリがありますけど
やっぱりそれでももう頑張って歌ったりはするし
ですから 我々威張ってるこの勉強っていうのは
まあそういうぐらいの動物でもやってるんだから
別にそんなに大したことじゃないんですね
で そこで問題は この自分が得た知識
本人に使えるかないか
そこら辺はから知恵の世界
ですから この世の中でみんな同じ教育を受けているんだけど
ある人々はいろんなひらめきがあって
いろんなことを作ったり
発明したりする 他の人は
ああ 何か自分も発明したらいいな
たくさんのお金も入っちゃって
これでいいなと思うだけでいいな
いいな でも全然できない
何か人に もうもう商売は行き詰まってるんだけど
いいアイデアないんですか？と言ったら
ある人はもういろんなもうもうバンバンアイデアを出したりするし
他の人々はもう同じ仕事をずっとやっているのに
そうですね 今の状況ではとか
ああだこうだとか もう何時間
何年経ってもなかなかいいアイデアが出てこない
もう脳細胞は動かないんですね
勉強しているんだけど
それはない それは知恵の世界なんです
そちらには論理がないんです
こういう風に考えれば
いいアイデアが出ますよと
そういう具体的な論理はないんです
それから 知識のためには
例えば徹夜してものを覚えれば
次の試験で何か合格できるかもしれませんだけど
知恵の世界にはそんな徹夜して勉強したんだからいいアイデアが出ましたよとか
そんなことさっぱりないんです
だから知恵のために勉強しようか
酒飲んで寝ようか そんな関係ないんです
出る時はすぐもうバンバン出るとアイデアが
で わかりやすく私はこういう風に例えで言うんですね
知識は道具を集まること
ある人は道具を集まる
普通の方々がなさっていることでも
買い物をするはするは
何か新しい新発売といっちゃったら
すぐ電話して取り寄せてもらうとかね
物は買うんだけど もう 2 3
年経ったら何買ったかとわからない
覚えてもない あれ なんでこれうちにあるんですか？とまた不思議に思う時もある場合あるんですね
道具は買うんだけど 使おうとしないんですね
知識っていうのは道具であって
いっぱいある でも使い方は知らない
使えないというのは知恵がないということで
ですから この知恵はすごい
もう極力実践的で 悪いということは全くない
実践的だから 知識にはいい知識
悪い知識はあるんです
知恵にはただいいだけ
なぜならば 知恵っていうのは何かのために使うということだから
で 皆様 それでも知恵がわからないと思うならば
こういうケース経験があるでしょうかね
あの いろんな家族関係やら社会関係があって
例えば学校を卒業できなかった人々いるんですね
ちゃんと高校を卒業できなかったと
あるいは中学ももう何とかあって
もうもう一応義務教育だから出たんだけど
結局いろんなことがあって勉強できなかったとか
それなのに よく頑張ってかなり裕福になったりして
会社なんか作ったりして
それまだたくさんいろいろ社員がいたりして
なんかそういう人々いるでしょ
我々の社会で そこで自分が大学卒業してる人は人々を雇うんですね
雇って その人々はその社長が言う通りにやるだけであって
社長は大学卒業でもないのに
あの よく新しいアイデアを出したりして行動する
それ その差があるんですね
それどういう差かというと
まあ知識はないんだけど
ひらめきは思い存分ある
いわゆる知恵の方が働いている
論理はない 論理じゃない
論理ですね そう 論理的なああだこうだとかね
例えば国際経済状態とか
これ売ったらこれぐらいで
これでこれでああだこうだとかね
そこまでは勉強してないんだからわからない
でも なんとなく今頃これやっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
すぐ知ってしまう なぜかと言っても
本人わからないかもしれませんだけど
そういうふうな この論理いらないひらめきの世界は
知恵の世界 知恵がなければ
知識は全くも役に立たない
それ 例えで言うならば
皆様は例えば 1ヶ月間
毎日新聞頭から最後までもう丸暗記しましたと
1ヶ月間の新聞を丸暗記したらすごい大したもんでしょ
全部宣伝まで全てのページを丸暗記したら
テレビでも出してくれるかもしれませんよ
すごい暗記力だから じゃああれで何になるんですか？何か役に立ちますか？何も役に立たない
そこで役に立つというのは
何か覚えていることは生きるために必要な時だけなんですね
ですから 知識っていうのは使えなきゃ何の意味もないんです
そこで知識はどのように使えるかというのは
知恵の世界です ですから
皆様にも知識 知識もあって知恵もあるんです
普通言うでしょ 生活の知恵とか生きる知恵とか
それはこの仏教の専門用語ではございませんが
知恵には変わりはないんです
生活の知恵だから 経験から得る知恵とか
だからありがたいのはどっちですか？ありがたいのは知恵の方なんです
今までなんとか生きているのは
生きていられるのは もうわずかでも知恵が働いているんだからなんです
そうでなきゃ もう本当に迷惑な存在なんです
人間というのは 単なる肩書きとか
いろいろ何々大学出ましたとかね
そんないくらあったっても
もう何も役に立たない場合は
もう何もできない場合はただの迷惑だけです
知恵の方は楽なんですね
でも残念ながら これには論理がないんだから
もう知識ではもう追おうとしたって追えるもんじゃないんだ
もう掴めるもんじゃないんです
数学だったらちゃんとした論理だから
まあ 2 3週間でも 1 ヶ月間でも頑張っちゃえば
もうすぐ身につくもんです
音楽でも体に慣らうもんだから
まあ一応きついんだけど
頑張ればできるもんなんですね
でも知恵はそうじゃないんです
楽器は演奏できるんだけど
それは美しく演奏できるのは
本当に素晴らしいことできるのは
もうちょっとプラスアルファで知恵がある人なんですね
ピアノにしても どんどん打つということは
まあちょっと勉強すればできるんです
でも ピアノからいい曲を曲を演奏できて
人々を感動させようということは
もうちょっと違う働きなんです
それは知恵の働きなんです
すべての世界にそれあるんです
ですから 科学はみんな勉強するんだけど
科学者は少ない ですね
みんな宗教も哲学も  日本ほどヨーロッパの哲学を勉強する国がないんだから
ヨーロッパ人もそれもそこまでやりませんだけどね
日本訳簡単に読めますからね
まあカントやらああだこうだよく読みますけどね
一人も哲学者いないんですね
ですから この勉強はできるんだけど
それは知恵がないと自分のものにならないんです
私の話は一番世の中で危ない
もう毒舌ばっかしで それは全然知恵がなくて
使ってみてください 知識だけで殺されるかもしれません
僕はわざわざとそういうふうにこの毒舌を言ってるんです
なぜならば 僕らにとっては
皆様方 知恵を発揮してこなきゃ
仏教でも何でもないんですね
幸福にはなりっこはないんです
ですから 僕は大胆な 爆弾的な
この危ない言葉っていうのは平気で言うんです
で それは消化できるのは知恵があるならば
まあこの人こう言っても
まあこういうこういうことではないかと
自分に知恵があるとそれわかる
人に話してあげることもできる
たまに僕に文句言う場合もありますね
自分が私が言うことに自分がすごく納得して
もう自分の個人的ないろいろ問題もなくなっちゃって
もう大変いいと思ってますよと
それを自分の父親も同じ問題で悩んでいるのか言われたところで怒られたんだと
バカにされたんだと あれ何ですか？と僕に聞くんですね
ああ それは僕は考えるのは
それはその通りだと いくら私が言った言葉をその通りに自分の父親に言ったっても
ただ知識は言ってるだけだから全然通じないんです
それバカにされますよ
そうされるように 僕はまあすごいきつい言葉で言ってるんだから
もし自分に身に添えて自分の知恵が生まれたならば通じるんです
で 教える場合でも 先生になって
教科書をきめ細かく砕いて
もういろいろ教えたっても
全然もう受けませんね
大体学生っていうのは
そこら辺にやっぱり自分の知恵で調理した方が
調味料は自分の知恵なんですね
知恵という調味料を入れちゃうと
もう受け入れちゃうんですね
そこで我々楽しいなのは知恵なんです
知識は苦しい 学校で教えるのは苦しいんです
でも 自分でいろんな工夫をしていろんなひらめきがあって
そのひらめきを使って教える時はなんとなく楽しい充実感が生まれる
勉強するのはもう大変苦しいことなんです
いろんな本を読まなくちゃいけない
メモを書かなくちゃいけない
書いたメモを忘れても意味がないんだから
覚えておかなくちゃいけない
整理しなくちゃいけない
それでまた忘れないように
またまたいろいろことをやらなくちゃいけない
大変きついです 勉強は
知識は でも知恵はきつくなく
すごい楽しい 疲れが飛ぶ
飛んでしまっちゃう 出てこない
ですから 知識と同時に知恵も得ておけば
もう大変幸福な世界ができてくるんです
人は不幸というならば
もう知恵がないということで
勉強していないんだから不幸っていうのはない
大学卒業しなかったんだから
不幸というのはない やっぱりいろんなひらめきがあって
知恵がある人は幸福で
知恵がない人は不幸であるんです
ですから 知恵の定義だけで終わりますけど
お話は まあまあ ちょっと一部に終わりにして
あの ちょっと短くにして話しますけど
で 知恵はそういう定義で
言葉はない 知恵の世界に論理はない
ロジックはないし それからわざわざ得ようとしてもして得るものでもないんです
ひらめきみたいなもので
ただボンボン浮かぶだけで
自然に 何か何か問題あったら
あ そうだったらそうしようと
すぐパッと浮かぶだけで
計画立てる必要はない
知識の全部反対なんですね
覚える必要はない 計画立てる必要はない
メモを取る必要はない
勉強する必要もない 論理もいりません
でも浮かぶ じゃあ知恵と道徳はどんな関係かというと
道徳を守らない ものすごいいい加減な生活をすると
大変精神的に乱れるんです
そうすると確実に知恵が働かなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 知恵にも道徳はもう無視することはできない
例えば バリバリ仕事をできる男性の方が元気で
一生懸命他のどっかの若い女の人に恋してみてください
奥さんのことを忘れて
どうなるんですかと どんどん仕事できなくなっちゃうんです
仕事に集中力できなくなっちゃうんです
そこで会社からいろいろ言われるようになるんですね
うちに行っても もううちで普通の夫として生活する知恵が出てこなくなっちゃうんです
するといろいろ混乱が生まれちゃうんです
するとどんどん疲れてきて
こういうこういうになっちゃうんで
ちょっとした道徳の乱れでも結構知恵に効くんです
はい だから知恵のために
知恵を作るために いつでもすごく明るくニコニコと
ストレス全くなく 楽しく生活しなきゃいけないんです
すごい心を明るくして
明るくと また軽く で 知識からいろんな悩み
苦しみ ストレス溜まっちゃうんです
ストレスは溜まれば溜まるほど
知恵が機能は失っていっちゃうんです
だからもうそこで最初のまあこれ最後にこれを覚えておいてください
知識はきつく疲れるもので
知恵は楽しく楽なもので
知識は勉強して覚えなくちゃ忘れるもので
知恵の場合は勉強するものも何もないんだ
忘れることも何もないんだ
そのまんまであって 知識は努力すれば得られるんであって
知恵っていうのは努力しなくたっても
それ関係なくどんどん現れるものであって
知識からは幸福になるか不幸になるかははっきりしないんですね
いわゆる道具ですから
それはうまく使うか悪く使うか
でも知恵の場合は必ずしも幸福をつかめるんです
知識には言葉があり 知恵には言葉がない
知識には論理があって
知恵には論理はなしと
ですから 科学は知識の世界で
知恵は科学ではありません
そういうところで まあちょっと一旦難しいんだから
皆様に知恵があるならば問題ないんだけど
まあないわけないんだけども
あの知恵があるならば
そんな私が話す必要はないんですから
でまあ一旦ちょっと 10 分ぐらい休憩して
あの  10 分でもいいし
15 分でもいいし  20 分でもいいんです
うん じゃあ 2回目の知恵のいくらか
この具体的にどうやれば知恵が生まれるかっていうことを説明した方がいいだろうと思いますが
あの まあ一つはこのもう考える世界じゃないんだから
とにかくこの何も考えないでしっかり目を覚めておく時間作れば目が覚め
咲いている 覚めてじゃなくて
僕はいつも咲いてるぐらい覚めてと言うんだけど
よく目が咲いて頭がしっかり咲いてるんだけど
瞬間だけ何も考えないで
何にも考えないで瞬間だけいてみる
難しいんです ですから
もし考えちゃったら また違いますよと
また考えないようにしますと
そこで眠くなっちゃったらまたダメなんです
すっごく目が咲いてる状態で何も考えないでいる
で こういうのは日常生活の中でも経験があると思いますね
別に この例えば仕事から行って疲れて
まあ熱いお風呂に入ってちょっと瞬間いるとすごい気持ちいいんですね
で 立ち上がったら何か今悩んでた問題とかあったならば
さっさとそれに答えが出たりとかね
あるんでしょ？あれ 何にも考えないで
ほんの瞬間でもいた ほんの瞬間でもいたならば
すぐ心がまあそれの必要な知恵が出してくれる
で だから今日もまあちょっと休憩あげたんだけど
その休憩の中で何にも考えずに目を閉じてじーっといたならば
次の第2部の勉強に必要な力もひらめきのもついてくるんです
ですから 頑張れば知識は得ますけど
その頑張るという余計に頑張るということはストップすると知恵が生まれてくる
必要なのは知恵なんです
でも 知恵があっても道具なければ動きませんね
運転はできるんだけど
車がないんだと じゃあ運転できないんですね
ですから このただ何もしないで
もう怠けていたっても
それは知恵でもなんでもないんだけど
で やっぱりそれなりの材料ね
知識として必要なんですが
知識のために努力する
知恵のために頑張るということをやめて休むということをする
で あの これ 哲学者の話を聞くと
何もしないで ただすごい哲学ばっかり喋ってる人々の話
ギリシア哲学者とか出てくるんでしょ
あれも知恵は働いてますけど
知識は使ってないんですね
だからどこかでも何もしないで
そういうなんか変な状態にはなりますけどね
まあこの必死で努力するんじゃなくて
心をちょっと休ませてあげるということは
知恵現れるために まあ一つの必要な条件
ものすごい必要な条件というよりはね
一つ必要な条件なんです
もう一つは 物事を信じないことなんです
それ 悪い言葉で言えばもう信じないことは何ですか？何でも信じるのはもうバカなんですね
あ そう すごいとかね あ
信じますよとか 知恵が生まれてこないんです
自分で努力しないんです
ですから もう普通のことを勉強やったり
普通に生きている場合は
生きている間では 人は言うんだから何でも信じるんじゃなくて
それは本当にその通りやかないかと
ちょっと頭で自分で判断しようとする
その心の怠け癖を取ってほしいんです
例えばテレビで何か何か言ってくれたら
すぐみんなそうですよと
いきなり そこは良くない
そうすると言われる通りにただの操り人形になるだけで
知恵が生まれてこない
だから本当なのかとね
本当かなとかね まあちょっとだけ自分でもそれは考えてみる
それは子供から大人までみんなに必要なものなんです
ちょっと自分で判断しようとする
何かセールスマンが来て物を売ろうとすると
ああ こうだったらすごいんですよ
すぐ決めちゃったら もう必ずそこでやられちゃうんですね
そういうことを本当かなと聞くと
自分に聞くと その欠点の方も見えてくるんです
で 同時に自分に知恵も生まれてくる
ですから  2番目の方法っていうのは
そういうふうに物事をすぐその通りに
人が言う通りに 耳に入る通りに
飲み込むということはストップして
ちょっとした腰を入れるんです
自分でもうもうちょっと考えてみる
完全に考えてみる必要はないんで
それは不可能なんです
例えば あの まあなんとかテレビでもうどこかの
湧き水で湧き水があります
それ飲んじゃったらもう美容にいいんですよと
いや それはもう片っ端から自分で行って試して研究するっていうことは不可能ですからね
他のものについてあっても
外国のニュースとか ああいうことでいくらでも出ますけどね
それなんだかんだで我々のは片っ端から自分で判断しましょうと
あなた方の判断は大きな抑えですよと思っても
それなんだかんだでもできるわけないんですね
ですから あまり厳密すぎじゃなくて
聞くものをもう見るものについて
ちょっとだけ自分でも考える
例えば ゴッホの絵はすごい綺麗ですよと
モネの絵はすごいんですよと
言うと みんなそう思っちゃうでしょ
あれは私だったらすっごく腹が立つんです
無知そのものだから 自分でも感じてみろと
自分の本心で汚い絵やらと思ったら
それでいいんです 別に言わなくても
人に合わせてすごいですね
やっぱりさすがゴッホやとかね
そんなもう無茶苦茶な何の意味もない話を言ってもいいんだけど
心の中であんた汚い絵だなとかね
で 自分の判断だから それやったらものすごい抜群の知識人に知恵の人になっちゃうんです
それでストレスもないんです
あの自分で判断する瞬間で
心のストレスは全部消えちゃうんです
この知恵が生まれる瞬間で
知恵こそはものすごい強力な癒しい機能を持ってる
癒す機能を持ってるんです
知識は体を壊す機能を持ってるんです
ですから  2番目で 2番として僕に言えるのは
もう常に目がいつでも冴えておいて
頭はね ちょっとほんのちょっと自分でも考えてみる
ですから わかり悪い言葉で言うならば
なんだかんだで丸呑み
うお呑みで信じるなと
このみんなそなた大勢と一緒になってわいわいと言っちゃうでしょ
それはもう もう人間らしくもないし
動物と同じで もう知恵のある人じゃないんで
とにかく 自分で行動できない
ですから みんな黒い色を着ているんだったら
自分もさっさと行って黒色の服を買って着るとか
みんな髪を長くしているなとわかったら
じゃあ私も髪を長くしなくちゃとか
そういうそなた大勢がやっていることをやっているのは
もうただの操る人間で
ロボット文化で機械文化で人間の文化ではないんです
それはすごい苦しいんです
みんなの真似しなくちゃいけないんだから
それごまかしちゃうんですね
日本は和の社会だと 和の社会っていうのは大変高度な素晴らしいことで
和を守るためにはよっぽどの人間ができていないとできないんです
そんな簡単単純なことじゃないんです
我々はわーわーというのは和ではなくて
ただまあ情けないというか
腰抜けというか 自信がないというか
逃げるんですね あれは和じゃないんです
ただの腰抜けなんです
ですから 日本の和の文化っていうのは
それはもう最高の素晴らしいことなんです
それは腰抜け性格でごまかしてはいけないんです
ですから まあですから
このそなた大勢と一緒に行動するんじゃなくて
自分の行動に自分で責任を持つ
ですから モネの絵でもゴッホの絵でも何でもいいんだ
絵でも何でもいいんだけど
みんな綺麗と言うんだから綺麗
とは決めないで 本当かなと
どうかなと 考えてみてください
だから私は今 知識の話で
この社会に対していろいろ悪口言ったでしょ？屁理屈だらけだ
ああだこうだとかね ああいうのは別に私はもう腹が立って悪口言ってるわけじゃなくて
本当かなと考えちゃったら
すぐ違う側面も見えてくるだけのことなんです
資本主義の警察こそやということは
僕は本当かなと見たところで
資本主義の国々ではものすごい貧富の差があったりして
こんなに日本にしたっても
ホームレスの家族がどんどん増えていったりしていて
ですから悲しいでしょう
ものすごくお金かかるんですね
日本で生きるためには
1ヶ月とかすごい膨大なお金がかかってしまっちゃうんです
そうすると普通の人間には生きていられないんです
鬼みたく金を儲けなきゃ
それはいいですかね 鬼みたく金を儲かるためには
もう鬼の親分みたいに自然を破壊しなくちゃいけないんですね
自分自身も破壊しなくちゃいけないんです
それでやっと生きてるだけで
だから一概にこれはいいや
これは悪いやとは言えない
それ思い浮かぶのは ちょっとだけ本当かなと思った時なんですね
別に攻撃的というわけじゃないんです
人はこれは美味しいんだから食べてください
言っちゃったら もういきなりどんと口に入れるんじゃなくて
まあちょっとどうかなという感じで口に入れてみる
よくも我々はこの固定概念で食べてますからね
まあよく有名だとフランスで食べてるんだと聞いちゃったら
もう何でも食べてしまう
臭いものでも すごい美味しいものでも
もうアジアとかアフリカとかどこかで食べてるなとわかったら
あ あんなものは日本人に口に合わないと平気で言うんです
食べたこともないのに
フランスのものだったら
カビ生えたものでも虫がいるものでも食べる
あれ食べてみてください
全然美味しくないんです
虫が入ったりとか カビが入ったりとか
やっぱりあの まあ食べるのは食べられないのは
それは個々の個人の大変ご自由なことだから
別にどうでもいいんだけど
僕はここで知恵のことを言ってるんだから
ちょっと自分でも物事を試してみましょうと
そうすると知恵には知恵が育ててくるんです
知恵っていうのは もしかすると
このまあ 邪教ですか 外道の教えから言うならば
もうジャイナ教とかね
そういう教えから見るも言うならば
もう自然にあるものなんです
完全に ただ我々はそれに苔いっぱい出てきて
もう邪魔しているだけなんです
知識で現れないように
ですから くだらない知識やら概念から心を綺麗になってリラックスすればするほど
本来の知恵がもう表に出るんだと
もともとあった知恵は
そちら辺にもいくらか筋は通ってるんです
っていうのは あの知恵っていうのは別に育てるもんじゃないんだから
ただ現れるために機会場を与えてあげる
ですから この 2番目に言ったこと
このことをちょっと自分でもほんのちょっと考えてみる
本当かなと そこをそう言ってもちょっと危険性あるんです
ただ単に反対しようと
何だかんだの それは何の意味もないんです
世の中のことは片っ端から批判してやろうではないかと
それは知識の世界で どこか心が病気なんですね
世の中のこと なんだかんだもうそうだそうだ
その通りだと言って和を守ろうというのは
どうか病気なんですね
どうか自信がないんだから
そういうものじゃないんです
ただの反対ではなくて
ほんのかすか遊びで本当かなとちょっと考えてみる
それはとことん本当ですから
試すことはできないものであるならば
そこら辺でほどほどに置いておく
まあわからないんだと
まあテレビで言ってるんだから
もしかすると本当でしょう
もしかすると嘘でしょうと
そういうふうに置いておく
このテレビのこの文化っていうのは
もうものすごい嘘を言う文化なんですね
で 映像の文化だからみんな信じちゃう
逆にそれは嘘の文化なんです
なぜかというと この間
このなんとかこの島でしたっけ
この小さい このアメリカに占領していたこの日本の方々
よく観光に行くところですけど
フィジーどっちかな そちら
このアメリカはもうてもう手を引いて援助もしないようになってるんですね
あと 3年経ったところで
今までもう普通の海で魚取って
ものすごく楽に生活していた人々は
もうこれからもう全くアメリカ式になっただから
もう大変なことになるんですね
そこでこの収入は全くないし
このタロイモと魚取って食べていたんですけど
誰も今タロイモを食べないんだそうで
みんな缶詰ばっかり食べて海での魚食べない
缶詰の食べて食べて魚食べる
もう 2 3回同じ番組を放映しましたけど
NHKで それでこの人事削減というか
この仕事といえば全部公務員だけ
政府の仕事だけで そこで 4分の 3ぐらいもうクビにしなくちゃいけないんですね
で そういうことで まあそれは事実なんですけど
それは口で言ったってわかりません
それで映像が流れるんですね
あるなんか事業の設計なんかしてやってる立派な人が
で その市長ですか 村長誰かわかりませんだけど
まあそれ誰かのこの責任者のところに呼ばれるんですね
そこでちゃんと向こうはまあじゃあ来て
だからこっちはポンポンとドアを叩いたりして
そこで中に入って その問題についてしゃべる
あなたはクビにするかしないかということ
そこで映像で NHK で撮っている
あれはもう完全に嘘なんです
やらせなんです なぜならば
そんな大事なことっていうのは
いきなりテレビカメラが入った時でしゃべるってこと
ありっこはないでしょうに
そういうことっていうのは
突然ある日現れた問題ではなくて
アメリカもちゃんと相談して
もうこれからはあなた方の面倒を見れませんと
我々はもうそこら辺で軍隊やったって意味がないんだから
我々のために引き上げますよと
あと 3年で援助が切れますよということはもう前からあった話で
ですから どうしよう どうしようかと何年もそういうことを考えてきて
クビになったら誰がクビになるんでしょうか
私がクビになるぞ あの人クビになるぞ
そういう話はいっぱいもありまして
自分の下で働いている人々のことはというのは
会社で 会社ではなくて
政府は自分でまあちゃんとした場でそれは考えていますよ
ディスカッションしますよ
このテレビカメラの前できちんと座って
まあそうですね 別にあなたは特別にクビにしたいという口実はないんですけど
じゃあどうすればいいんだ
それはまあ 単なる正真正銘のやらせなんですね
でも 普通の知恵でないと見るとそれは気がつかないんです
本当はあれは面白い番組じゃなくて
ちゃんとしたドキュメンタリーなんです
ちゃんとしたドキュタリーであろうとも
もう 90%も映像は信頼できないんです
ですから このだからで
僕はその国の真実を知ってますかと言えば
もう全然知りません 名前もはっきり思い出せませんだからね
で 僕にとっては名前はどうでもいいんです
僕は知恵の働きだけ考えているんだから
ただ あの こんな現代社会のね
まあテレビニュースであっても
やっぱり信頼性は欠けているんだと
新聞に新聞の方が稼ぎだから
人は勝手に考えるんだから
その場合は個人がね いくらか信頼性あるんだけどね
いくらでもその分信頼性ないんです
なぜならば事実があって
記者がいるんですね 記者が自分に把握できたものしかメモを取らないんですね
それで読む人々はどうやって読んで面白がってくるのか
まだ読む人々のことを想像しちゃうんですね
して作品書くんです ですから
新聞というのは その記者たちの勝手な作品であって
その中に漏れちゃうんですね
事実 いくつか ただそれだけ
それで我々は新聞記事にあったのではないかというふうに
すごくそれは証拠に出すんです
知恵っていうのは そういうふうに
この裏のからくりを知ることなんです
カーテンの向こう側をちょっと開けて
ちょっと覗いてみると
どうなっているんですか
その気持ちなんですね
ですから 見るもの聞くもの
そのまんまうのみするんじゃなくて
本当かなと どうかなと
ちょっと明るい気持ちで
ほんのかすかに考え直す
自分で考える 考え直すじゃなくて
いわゆる自分の意見も持つということなんですね
ちょっと考え直してみる
そうすると またいろんな違うものを見えてくる
それですごく面白い 自分で発見するものだから
その面白さによってすごくリラックスもできる
で 元気にもなる で それから仕事にもなる
仕事に必要なのは 物事を言う通りにやってくれるロボットではありません
経済状態はきちんと動いているならば
ロボットで結構です 経済状態ちょっとガタガタになってくるとロボットでは困るんです
新しいものを考え出しちゃって
新しくチャレンジして新しく競争する人々は必要なんです
だから 今までヨーロッパの方は経済的に力強くて
アメリカの方がすごく経済状態が良くて
もう日本のものは何でも買っちゃうと
そこで日本はすごい経済成長
経済成長と謳っていたんだけど
アメリカはちょっとストップと言ったところで
もうぐるぐると倒れちゃうでしょ
なんで世界一力の強い国がちょっと一言で倒れるんですかね
そこは良くないんですね
倒れるということは だから
あ 状況変わったよと 状況が変わったならば
この経済状態をどうやって維持しますか？という場合は
ロボットではものすごく困るんです
朝きちんと 30 分  1 時間早く会社に行って
仕事をなくても 1 時間半ぐらい会社に泊まっていて
うちに帰る連中はただの迷惑なんです
じゃなくて ああしたらいいんじゃない
こうすればいいんではないかと文句ばっかり言っている
この嫌な人々は その時は助けになるんです
じゃあこうしようと じゃあこの商売を
じゃあこの会社潰れましょうと
潰しちゃって もう新しいことを作ろうではないかとか
そうするともう生き延びることというか
何といいますか 生存することはできるんですね
だからやっぱりなんだかんだ言っても必要なのは知恵なんです
ひらめきの世界なんです
この仕事で困った困惑という人々は
ほとんどこの知恵がないというか
使わないというか もう
そこで問題を作ったりするんです
知恵がある場合は どんなくだらない仕事でも面白おかしくやることはできるんです
一応 2番目はちょっと長く言いましたけど
大事なポイントで 自分でちょっと自分でも考えてみる
考えてみて そこから現れた知恵も知恵でもいいし
知識でもいいし それもまた持っていく自分のものとして
そうすると 3つあるんです
一つは自分の知識 もう一つは社会から入る情報
社会からの情報にはもう判断して入れてくれるんですね
これは素晴らしいニュースや
これは悪いニュースやと
もう判断もうすでにしているんです
記者であろうか  そういうレポーターする人々が
自分の浅い知恵で 知識で
ですから 我々はすでに持っている知識と入ってくれる知識と自分で作った
ただ自分だけの知識ってあるんですね
自分で判断したものもありますから
世の中で誰にもない自分だけのもの
その３つを一緒に並んでおくと
パッと何か浮かんじゃうんです
それは知恵なんです で
そういう風にこの 常に
自分で考えること 次に言いたいのは
このワンパターンにマンネリとかね
ありますね みんなそうなりたがっちゃうんですね
何かパターンを決めて
マニュアルをマニュアルを作って
その通りに生きていきたいんですね
あれこそ知恵に毒はないんです
で みんな落ち着くんですね
もう毎日決まってる時間で起きて
決まってる食べ物を食べて
決まってる時間で家を出て
決まってる仕事をして
で 決まってる時間で帰って
決まってる店に行って酒を飲んで
もう決まってる時間でもう家に戻ると
そこで決まってる挨拶を交わして
で 決まってるパターンでお風呂に入って
布団を敷いて 決まってる人に布団敷いてもらって
そこで寝ると もし奥さんではなくて
子供がちっちゃな子供が布団敷いちゃったら
どうせいい加減ですから
子供にできませんだからね
それだったら何かちょっとおかしくて寝られないんですね
決まってることちょっと変わりましたから
そこだったら 人生はもう知恵のところじゃないんです
それまたロボット文化で
それは良くない ですから
まあ私たちにはこの社会は変えることできない
社会のことを変えることはできないんです
例えば 会社は 9時に仕事が始まるんだったら
やっぱり自分はもう朝 4時に起きてもう運動してるんだから
まあ 6時になっちゃうと
もうご飯も食べてすごい元気ですよと
奥さんもいなしですから
自分で何か朝ごはん作って
もう食べて  5時から起きて運動して
6時は食べて もう汗も出て元気なんですね
だからその場ですぐ会社に行くことはできるんですね
だから会社の門でちゃんと 6時半から仕事を始めなさいとというのはちょっとおかしい話で
迷惑であってね そういうふうに社会変えることはできないんです
会社が 9時だと決めているならば
どうせ 9時に行けばいいんです
でも 私たち個人でこのパターンにはめられないようにしなくちゃいけないんです
決まってるマンネリは
パターンは一応守ってはいるんだけど
精神的にはめられてロボットにならないように気をつけなくちゃいけない
どういうことを工夫すればいいかと具体的に言うならば
何でもね 新しいんだと
昨日は昨日で 今日は今日ですよと
昨日のこと同じく今日もあるわけじゃないんだと
今日と同じく明日もということはないんだと
毎日チャレンジだと 今日は仕事うまくいったんだから
じゃあよし 元気付けて自信があって明日もやるぞと思ったって
それはちょっと危ない
今日うまくいっても 明日はうまくいかないかもしれません
今日叱られたんだから明日も叱られるわけじゃないんです
ですから 常に目が咲いておいて
目が開いておいて 知識の目を
毎日物事は違うんだと
同じ現象に 2度と会わないんだと
いつでもこの過去のものを置いておいて
新しい心を作って じゃあ今日に今日出会うものに一つ一つチャレンジしていきますと
それ終わっちゃったら
まあ終わったんだから
じゃあ次の問題と あの
何でしたっけ？この例は良くないんだけど
このコンベアベルトというものあるんですね
生産の過程では このコンベアベルトの概念では
このものは流れてくるんですね
自分には決まっている仕事があるんですね
そこでさっさと仕事をする
そこで自分のところに届いた品物に何かネジ一つ入れるとかね
あるいは袋に入れるとか
何か決まってる仕事かもしれませんだけど
それやりながらどれぐらい流れてくるんですかね
たくさんなりますねと
考えちゃどうなるんですか？こちらの仕事はできなくなっちゃうんですね
そこで言ったベルトにそこを言ったものについて
ああ 今日はこれぐらい作ったな
まあ結構やったね 俺の我なりにとか思っちゃうと
こちらはもう全部 ですから
勝負は瞬間だけであって
ここから流れるものはどうでもいいし
こちらから出ている それは関係ないんですね
だから勝負は今日ありと
全部新しいんだと それ 1週間頑張っていれば
その気持ちで見違えるほど人は生まれ変わっちゃうんです
とことん頭に叩き込んでおいて
瞬間瞬間新しいんだと
同じパターンで物事起こるわけじゃないんだと
叩き込んで世の中を見て生きてみてください
1週間ぐらい もう人は生まれ変わるんです
新しい知恵の世界に 全く違うように世の中見えてくるんです
残念ながら 何だかんだでマニュアル通りに子供にご飯作ってあげることもちゃんとテキスト通りにと
子供を躾けたい時も ちゃんと本能通りにやろうとする
自分で考えようとしない
だから知恵はまるっきりなし
子供の抱き方 おっぱいのあげ方まで教えてくれるんだから
笑われちゃうんでしょうに
あれ自然なことだから
自分を産んだ子にもうおっぱいはあげられませんというならば
教えなくてももう何とかやりますよ
なんであんなくよくあるんですかと
わからないんです なんか人間人間恨んでるでしょと思いますけど
私は 人間恨んで金を儲けようとしているんだからね
だからもうお母さんたちがね
初めての子が授かったところで
やっぱりそういうところに行ってお金払って
いろいろもう指導を受けたりはする
だからといって完全に悪いわけじゃないんだけど
それなりに役に立つ部分があるんだけど
あまりにもそういうものに頼っちゃうと
自分で考えなくてもいいんですね
子供の料理の順番が全部それなりのお医者さんか栄養士がもう考えてリスト書いてるんだから
あれリストにあるものをあげればいいんです
あれで知恵は生まれてこない
ものすごくつまらない人生は
なぜならば刺激がないんですね
生きてるんだと 例えば
自分で何か料理を工夫して作る
作って赤ちゃんに食べさせたところで
硬いものを食べられるようになったところで
赤ちゃんがひどい顔をして食べなかったと
そうすると あ これは失敗だという
あるんですよ 何か勉強になるものが
そこでなんで赤ちゃんがあれを食べなかったんですか？と考えちゃったら
自分でも食べてみたら
やっぱりそれ自分にでも嫌という
じゃあこういう風にしようと
で 次の日やったところで
赤ちゃんがすごい喜んでニコニコ笑いながら食べちゃったならば
自分もすごい なんかどうかで競争で勝ったような
1等賞を取ったような感じがするんじゃないんですか？よく食べてくれたんだと
そういうふうに瞬間瞬間新しいチャレンジがあるんです
例えば 赤ちゃんが泣くたびにおっぱいあげるとかね
すごいくだらないんですね
そうじゃなくて 今はもしかするとお腹が空いてるだろうと
でもまあ今はもうちょっと面倒くさいんだから
あとあと 10 分経ったところでおっぱいあげますよと
でも赤ちゃんはお腹が空いてるんだから泣いちゃうでしょ？じゃあどうすればいいんですかと
いつでも泣くたびにオッパイあげるっていうわけじゃもうないんだから
人はいろいろまた他の仕事もあるんだから
電車でおっぱいあげたって何のこともないんだけど
自分が電車で立ってると
その時赤ちゃんが泣き出しちゃう
座ってるんだったらおっぱいあげられますけど
その瞬間にマニュアル通りにはいかないでしょうに
自分で何か考えなくちゃいけない
何かして赤ちゃん 赤ちゃんの意識を他の方に向けちゃって
なんとか騙さなくちゃいけないんですね
泣かないように そういうふうに人生っていうのは
ほんの瞬間 瞬間 我々にひらめきが出てくるっていうのは
いつでも瞬間 瞬間あるんですね
ですから マニュアル文化を蹴っ飛ばさない限りは
これは社会的に蹴っ飛ばすんじゃなくて
個人の心の心はそれに汚染されないように
マニュアル通りにやる
その方が安全だから もしマクドナルドとかそういうファーストフードの店にバイトにでも行ったならば
どういうふうにハンバーグを作るんですかと
ちゃんと映像絵で描いてるんですね
そこで自分でじゃあトマトを控えめようとかね
もうちょっとからしを多めに入れようとか
もう余計なことをしなくてもいいんです
その場合はもう言ってる通りにやりながら
だからといって 自分の人生までマニュアルにするのはおかしいんですね
ですから やり方はわかりやすくなれば
今日は今日だけですと
毎日自分が出会う問題は全く新しいものだと
ですから その場で考えなくちゃいけないんだと
それに今までの経験と勉強と知識と何だかんだでもまあ使うんだけど
結論はその場で出しますと
で たまに僕に言われる場合ありますね
こういうふうに上司に言われたんだと
その場合はどうすればいいんですかと
僕は具体的な答えは出さないんですね
なぜかというと あなたに上司はそういうふうに言われた
あ その場合はこういうふうに返事した方がいいよと言ったら
すぐそれ上乗せにするんですね
それを覚えて じゃあ次
上司にこう言ってあげますと準備して行くんだけど
次の日は同じ言葉でしかありませんだから
だからせっかく私からもらった知恵は役に立たないんです
そういうことだから 私は具体的な答えは出せません
具体的な答えを出してほしい場合は
僕はみんなに言うのは
私を現場に入れてみてくださいと
現場でちゃんと見せて見せます
具体的な例 どんな問題でも
でもそれは猿まにしたっても
他の人にはダメなんです
その人は自分で その瞬間
自分でやった問題に ちゃんと対応しなくちゃいけない
例えば ある人の奥さんがものすごくヒステリーを起こしちゃって
もうものすごいトラブルを起こしているんだと
そこでお坊さんなんとか言って
なんとか言って言ってあげくれませんかと言ったら
僕ははいわかりましたよと言って
その奥さんと話して抑えてくれることはできるんです
それを外から見ていた旦那が
よし その方法で私もやりますよと
これ冗談じゃないんです
それはうまくいかないんです
だから あまり具体的な例に頼るんじゃなくて
具体的な例も使って自分で判断しちゃう
そのために必要なのは
この物事はいつでも新しいんだと
今日の日は昨日と違ってどうなるかとわからないチャレンジの日ですと
まあちょっとした何かビクビクしたような感じで
学校の先生であろうか
もう毎日行ってるんだからつまらないわではなくて
今日はどんなことになることやとわからないんだから
どうせまあとにかくよし
行ってやるぞという気持ちで毎日行くと
毎日面白いんです で 知恵も生まれてくる
仕事にもなる ストレスもないし
幸福も感じる それは知恵を育てる3番目の方法なんです
まあ 1週間ぐらいもう厳密にやってしまえば
もういきなりすごい人は変わったほど変わるんです
知恵の世界 3番目に行きます
で あ  4番目 指でも数えとかないといけないです
数えておいたって またこうやっちゃってまた忘れちゃう
で 物事にはちゃんとしたこのハイレスですか
因縁関係というか もうちゃんと順番のようなものがあるんですね
それは仏教でいう因果法則なんです
いわゆる偶然というのはなし
何でもきちんとした因縁によって生まれてくるんです
ですから 何か問題に出会う瞬間で
すぐそこら辺にこの問題なぜ現れたかという
そのすぐその場の因縁がわかってくるんです
それを発見してほしい
もっと違う言葉で言えば
現れる現象のからくりを理解しようと
すぐそれ瞬時に あの前言ったでしょ？ちょっと本当かなと
ちょっと見てくださいと
物事をそうやっちゃうと
1番目に行ったのはそれでしょ
すぐこのからくり見えてくるんです
4番目としてそれを使うんです
で からくり こうでこうだからこうなったよと
すぐわかったら すぐそこに答えが出てくるんです
あるこの前もこちらで同じ例を申し上げましたけど
ある二人が大変喧嘩になったところで
もう一人は喧嘩しませんだけど
一人は怒ってまあ散々いろんなことを言うんです
そこで そこを見ていたもっと知恵のある人が
まあそれに論理的に合理的に言おうとしなかったんですね
あなたはこうこう言ったっても
あの人はこうこうではないか
ああだこうだとか言ったっても
怒りは収めないんですね
いきなりあなたは正直者ものですからね
それだけ言ったんです
それで抑えたんです どういうことかというと
この人はある人のことを気に入らなくて
もう悪口言ってるだけで
それは決していけないことで
人の悪口は自分だけ  ああだこうだと
とにかくあの人はすぐわかったのは
その人はものすごく物事を自分には上手にできるんだとかね
自分もやらなくちゃいけないんだとか
とにかく自己を出したいんですね
自分を出したいんですね
なかなか出す場がなかったんで
それで腹が立ってるんです
それにずっと説法したっても効かない
怒りを収めない だから瞬時にそれをわかってしまっちゃうんですね
やっぱり自分には立場がなかったんだから
今怒ってるんだと ですから
あの人は正しいと言うんじゃなくて
あなたも正しいんだと言うんじゃなくて
全く違うことを言っちゃうんです
あんたすごい正直ですねとか何とか言っちゃったら
本人がわけわからなくなっちゃって
もしかする？なんとなく落ち着いちゃうんですね
一つは もしかするとこの人は私の言うことは認めましたと誤解するかもしれません
あるいは私は正直者だと言われたんだから
やっぱり正直者は立派な性格だから
私は立派な態度を取らなくちゃいけないんだと
今の自分の態度は立派じゃないんだと
いくらね 人を批判することは立派じゃないんだから
そういう何とかの働きが働いて
瞬間にあの人の怒りが消えちゃったんです
消えて問題は解決と ですから
この問題の遠い原因を探す必要はない
まあありますが そこを遠い原因を探してもらって答えを出すと
もう 1時間  1年ぐらいかかるんです
人は今問題を作っているんだから
今答えを出さなくちゃいけない
特に精神的な問題の場合は
まあいろいろ過去世まで遊ぶ連中いるんですね
思い出させて 小さい まあ 1年前どうなったんですか？ 2年前どうなったんですか？ 5年前どうなったんですか？ 10年前
小さい時はどういうことですか？とか
そこでも原因見つからなかったら
過去まで人をなんとかさせたりしてとかね
それは本当か嘘かわかりませんだけど
かなり時間かかるんですね
そういう精神的な治療に行っちゃったら
今の悩み 今すぐ直した方がいいんです
今キャーキャーともうやってるならば
なぜ今こうなったんですか？と
例えば ある人がすぐヒステリーになるんだと
ちょっとしたことで それは小さな小さい時の経験かもしれませんよ
小さい時 何かあって それはどんどんどんどんどんどんヒステリー性格に
あるいは多重人格になっちゃったんだと
そこまで行って直そうとするならば
5  6年  7  8年 たまに大体ほとんど治りませんだから
一生かかっても治らないというかね
それよりは生きているのは今の瞬間だから
今の瞬間で なぜ今ヒステリーになったかと
すぐ見つかって それに何とかしちゃう
例えば人があるもので
ものすごい一緒にやって
もう私はこんなことをやっていられません
ああだこうだとかね もうあの人と一緒に仕事はもう絶対できませんとか
何とかしてくださいとか
言うかもしれません それでそう言ったっても
会社は会社だからね あなたは他のところに行くわけにもいきません
その人はもう他の転職するかで
そんな簡単にできませんしとかね
いい加減だとか言ったっても意味がないんです
その場合 すぐあなた ちょっと他の何かあったら頼めばいいでしょ
この資料をちょっと向こうの 3階まで持っていって
あの人に渡してくれませんか？とかね
あるいはちょっと買い物でもして
なんかケーキでも買ってくれませんかと
ちょっとケーキ食べたかったんですけど
女子ですからね 言えるし
あのことと何の関係なくなんとか言ってあげると
そうするとすごい すぐそこの瞬間で消えちゃうんですね
あの状態は 本人が帰ってくると
あの文句も何もなく また仕事に戻るんです
だからそのだから すぐその瞬間で答えを出して
そこで問題を押さえてくれれば十分です
また問題を作ったらまた抑えてあげちゃう
それ何回繰り返しちゃうと
その人は簡単に治りますし
それでも治らない場合はもう一応余裕があるんだからトラブルを起こしません
起こしたらここで全部解決する
で 余裕があるんだから
ゆっくり精神科のところに行ってカウンセリングでも受けて
まあゆっくりあなたの原因を直してくださいということも言えるし
だから この物事の配列というか
なぜこんなことになったかと
ただそれだけ 見て すぐそれに答えを出すということも一つの方法なんですね
これ ちょっとやりにくいかもしれませんね
一応 物事は偶然には現れません
自分の旦那さんが偶然
あの 何て言いますか 不倫というんですか
このするようになったと
ある日突然というのはないんです
それなりの原因結果がまとめたところでそうなるんであって
そこら辺知っていると
なんとかすることはできるんです
ですから この お医者さんもやるような感じで
このすぐ何とかしなくちゃいけないんだよ
とにかく あるいは子供は学校で喧嘩して
ものすごくカンカン怒って
もう怒りで涙泣きさん家に来て
バーンとドアを開けて
靴なんか捨ててあっち捨てて
もう部屋に帰ってもいろいろ親言うことも聞かない
ああいう状態たまにあるんですけど
そこでもういちいちこっちで何ですか
その態度はとか あそこだとか言って
そうじゃなくて 今怒っていて混乱状態ですと
まず混乱状態を何とかしようと
人が混乱して怒っていると
何をすれば治りますか？簡単でしょ
その場合は まあちょっと面白いことを言ったりとかね
あるいはもう考えたこともない何か他のことを言ったりとか
あるいは自分の子供だったら
まあね ちょっと頭なでてあげるとかね
どうですか？とかね 何も言葉かけなくてもいいし
たまに まあちょっとスキンシップぐらいとかね
たまに 例えば子供が喧嘩して血だらけで泥だらけで来たんだけど
なんでどういうことになった？自分も必死になっちゃうでしょ
それは危ない そうじゃなくて
ああ やれやれと言いながら
ちょっと顔をね 拭いてあげるとか
こんな可愛い顔ももう台無しですよ
なんとか言いながら あれぐらいですごくじーんと心落ち着いていくんです
何の原因も探索しないで
あれだけで  それから子供は自分で言い始める
実は今日はね こういうことになったんだよとか
ああだこうだとか あ そうとかね
だからすぐこのそのことをやらないんだから
もうほとんど失敗しちゃうんですね
自分の子供が喧嘩してうちに帰っちゃったら
そのお母さんがすぐ次の日
うちの入って そのうちの子供に喧嘩を売っちゃうとするんだからね
学校に行って先生に喧嘩を売ろうとするんだからね
私はこういう関係ならば
全部学生の学校の先生たちに教えてあげるんだよ
お母さんが来たらぶん殴れと
何も聞かないで そうすると怖くて学校に行かないんだから
だからみんな問題は大きくするだけで
解決しようと気持ちないんです
自分の子供殴られちゃったら
すごい自分の我が出てきて
自分のプライド傷ついたんだと
そんな感じで言って 先生に悪口を言わ
殴った子供に悪口を言わ
その両親に悪口を言わ
自分のもう悩んでいる子供のことは全然平気なんです
そうじゃなくて 泣きながら来たらね
ちょっとだけもうハグですか
まあちょっとスキンシップしてあげて
ちょっと顔を拭いてあげて
もう髪の毛もちょっとだけ
別に意味そんな大した意味がないんだけど
それは子供自分でやるかもしれませんね
その時は 乱れてる服をちょっと直してあげたりとかね
なんか違うことをやって
あの状態を慰めてあげる
そうするともしかしたら何のこともなくなるかもしれない
まあ大したことないんですよと
子供は言うかもしれません
子供は大したことないというならば
大したことはないし ですから
この余計なことを考えるんだから
みんなどうせ一般の社会っていうのは理屈の社会じゃないんだから
その上 理屈だと思ってさらに変なことを考えちゃう
ですから 私 知恵が現れるために言うのは
すぐその場でなぜこんなことが起きたかとか
どうすればこんな現象が消えるかと
すぐその場でなんとかすると
なら まあ具体的な例っていうのはわかりやすいんだけど
まあ言っちゃったら それまた鵜呑みにしてその通りにやろうと思っちゃうとね
困りますから あまり使えない例しか僕には出せないんですね
で  仏教の立場から言うならば
やっぱりこの物事の因果関係を知ると
その因果関係を知ったならば
この原因 この果 この結果はこの原因で現れたと知ってますからね
そこで この結果は次にこういう結果の原因になるんだと知ってます
だから今の状況は変えなきゃいけないんだと
現在の果状態 悩んでいる子供を喧嘩してくる子供の
その今の状態だけ変えてあげれば大丈夫なんです
いろいろ相談 ディスカッションして
子供の性格やら学校の行き方
教え方 そこまで行かなくてもいいんです
みんなそこら辺ちょっと何かおかしいだけですけど
あまり遠く遠くまで走っちゃうんです
それも必要 それはもうそれには時間の余裕が必要なんです
例えば怒ってきた子供は
すぐ帰ったらすぐ家の中で
もし母が何か引き金を引いたならば爆発しちゃうんです
そこで一旦家の中で暴力を振るったならば
次の結果も必ず決まっているんですね
だから この学校の教育うんぬんとか
教室の仲間のことうんぬんとか
そんなことを喋る暇がある
よくあるんですね みんなに
そうじゃなくて すごく怒りで考えになった子は
もう母もまた無責任なんか言っちゃったら爆発するんだから
まずその火を消すと それが大事なの
僕は自分の例なんですけど
ある日 ちっちゃな子供二人がすごい喧嘩して
まあもう服はむちゃくちゃ
まあもうになっちゃって
もうもう破れちゃって
泥だらけで 雨の中でも何の訳もなく喧嘩して
そこで一人はすごい喧嘩したがる
ものすごい もうもうなんかもう蜂みたいな
ちょっとひらで攻撃するんです
僕らの言葉でも八と四です
もうすぐ喧嘩する人と人は
で  もう一人の子はまあ別にそんな程度じゃないんだけど
とにかく喧嘩になっちゃう
大体この落ち着いてる人なんですね
喧嘩の引き金を作るのは
我々は逆に思ってますけどね
どうせ性格が悪い人はどうせ性格が悪いんだから
あまりもう別に何のことないんです
それ 誰かが何か言うんですね
何か言っちゃったら こっちはもうすぐ爆発しちゃうんです
だから全然よく勉強できて
性格良くて落ち着いてる子だけど
いつでも喧嘩的な人に何か言っちゃうんだから
その何か言ったことで爆発してぶん殴られて怪我して
そうすると先生たちが素晴らしいいい子を殴ったんだと
こいつは前々からも悪いんだと言って
あの人の立場を取っちゃうんです
どうせ心の中でも それで問題解決しない
そういうケースの場合
僕に実際に会った瞬間で
僕にはその解決する暇もないんで
忙しくて忙しくて 子供の扱いは他の人々に任せてあったし
その人々はもう手に負えないんですね
あんまりにも喧嘩やってるんだから
もう仲介できないほどちっちゃいんだから
別に二人とも捕まっちゃったらもう終わりますけど
それでまあ大人が行って
もうやめなさいと言って二人分けちゃったら終わったんだけど
それでももう捕まってるのは相手蹴飛ばすをしてるんですね
で どうしようもないんだから
離すわけにはいきません
離しちゃったらまだやっちゃう
ですから 二人でこのちっちゃな子供二人を捕まって
どうせずっと捕まっぱなしでダメですし
どうしようもなく私のところに連れてきちゃうんです
私は他のことをやって
僕は何のことなく あの
誰が悪い人か 誰がいい人かと関係なく
二人とももう口を準備しているんですね
これからもうもうちゃんと自分の立場を正しいと言ってやろうと
弁解必要ではないかと
僕はそれも聞かなくて
やれやれ なんだお前 泥だらけでまあ汚くて
で そこから全く違う方向に問題を持っていったんですね
いわゆるその子供のことを心配しているところに持っていったんですね
君は泥だらけで汚くて
ああ嫌だなとかね いうのは親の心だから
やっぱり綺麗にいてもいいしという気持ちだから
それはちゃんと子供に通じるんですね
そこで捕まってきた人に
あんた この子ちゃんと洗ってあげてよと
なんのこともなく それで洗ってあげたんです
次の子も同じく もうそれほど汚れてなかったんだけど
それもちゃんと拭いてあげたりして
で 終わっちゃうと まあもう家に帰ってね
着替えてこい それだけ
それで問題終わりと 誰が悪いか
誰が正しいか そんなことは別にどうでもいい
問題は解決だから それっきりもあの二人は喧嘩にならない
あの子はものすごくいい子になっちゃったんだから
あんな喧嘩的な子は今大きいんだけど
今あまりもおとなしく
で 今度行ったら僕は お前おかしいでしょうと
喧嘩するんだったら今でしょうと
ふざけて悪ガキやるんだったら今でしょ
今もうそろそろもう十六か十五歳ぐらいなんですね
まだ体は小さいんだけど
遊び回るんだったら今でしょ
今おとなしくなってどうするんですかと
そう言われるぐらいも落ち着くというもんですから
ちょっとしたことで ですから
この それを私のやり方で
だからといって子供は
じゃあ喧嘩したら洗ってあげようとか決めるんじゃないんです
だから具体的な例は言いたくないんです
僕はすぐ読むのは やっぱり
いくらなんでも子供っていうのは
やっぱり自分のことを心配してくれると
その人にはちゃんと反応するということなんですね
心配してくれる人 してくれる人々には裏切ってはいけないんだと
それぐらいは本能として知ってるんです
だから正直に心配してあげる
それは行動にも表してあげる
余計な行動ではなくて
必要な時 行動でも示す
それ同じ子のことなんですけど
ある日 お母さんが私に子供のことを言うわ言うわ
いや 子供にいるんですね
本当にもうこのこいつはもう嫌ですよ
言うこと聞かない ああだこうだ喧嘩するは勉強しないとかね
もう人生まで嫌になっちゃったんだと
これ散々子供の悪口を私の前で言うんですね
で 私の子供はいくらか仲がいいということは知ってるんだから
もう信頼して言うんですけどね
だといっても 子供にとってはすごい自分のプライドが傷つくでしょ
で 先生にあげますから
なんとかもう何でもいいんで何とかしてくださいと
私は嫌ですよとか これ母親そんなことを言っちゃうと
お母さんそんなこと言っちゃなんて
いかに子供に対して失礼かと思いつつ黙っているんですね
何も反応しない 答えない
で そちらに海 川があったんです
川を渡る橋があったんです
みんな車でいたんです
で 僕はいきなり運転手に
そっちちょっと車止まってくださいと
川のところに 橋のところに
いきなりだから何の意味もないんだからね
まあ何ですか？と言ったら
何ですか？いえ こいつをこの川に捨てたいんですよと
僕の反応 それだけなんですね
じゃあ止まってください
こいつを今このまま川に捨てますからと
そう言っちゃったら やっとお母さんも落ち着いちゃって
子供も気持ちよくなっちゃったんですね
今まで母親が自分に恥かかせて
恥かかせて もし私はそのまま丸のみにしちゃったら
あの子は私にも会わせる顔がないんだから
で それに僕はいきなり僕の反応は
じゃあ海に 海じゃなくて
じゃあ川に捨てよう そこにすごくヒューマーがあって
子供は可愛いというふよぎがあるでしょ
それは川に捨てようということは
別に川に捨てる意味じゃないんだから
誰もそんなことしないし
であの奥もやっぱり今いろんなことをお母さん言ってもね
やっぱりあまり聞いてないんだと
この人は そこでやっとその二人が落ち着いたんですからね
今は問題ないんだけど
ですから その答えっていうのは自分ですぐ出す必要あるし
それはやっぱりすぐその場のことを判断することから生まれてくる
で もう時間は消えちゃったんだけど
またいっぱい本番がまだ入ってないんで
知恵の現れる本番は それはただの
何て言いますか 舞台で一番初めに何と言いますか
あれはもう 前座だけなんです
またいっぱいあるんですけど
残念ながら時間はないんです
で 次に一つだけでも言っておきますけど
あの 物事の逆 を考えてみましょう
みんな言ってる通りに
これだからこうなります
これだからこうなりますと言うんだけど
そちらの反対もあります
どんな論理にも どんな考え方にも
その反対の考え方もあるんです
それも考えておきましょう
いわゆるこういう論理です
すべての論は反論を持っている
正っていうのは 負というものは必ず持っています
そこを両方考えてほしい
例えば 子供ってよく言うことを聞いてくれると
よく勉強するというのはありがたいでしょ
それは逆はなんですか？あの子供には自分の独立性はない
自分で考えることはできない
でしょ 言う通りにするんだから
攻撃できない そしていい子にしようと自分を責めなくちゃいけない
自分の正直な気持ち 自分の精神的ないろいろ葛藤とかね
表せない それでものすごいひどい目になっちゃうんです
大人になっちゃうと それの逆の
それは逆の論理なんですから
やっぱり子供だから親言うこと
大人言うこと 先生言うことを聞きなさいと
それは当たり前ではないかということでもないんです
そちらの反論も考えてほしい
そこで じゃあそれだったら子供はわがままで
自分の気持ちはもう表したい放題表したりして
先生に思い存分反発したりして
すればどうなるんですかと
そうするときちんとした独立性でき上がるんではないかと
違うんです そうすると何も勉強できない
わがままで 自分はそのまんまで成長しない
なぜなら自分の感情ばっかり出したりするでしょ
そうすると全然成長しない
進化はなし そのまんま
言うことを聞くと変化はあるんだけど
個人は死んじゃって ただのロボット
麻原のところであの人々はね
頭の勉強できる 頭悪いんだけど
勉強できる人々はあれほど悪いことをしたのは
いい子で育てられたんだなんです
だからなんです 自分で考えられない
人殺しといえば ああ そうですね
先生に言われるんだから
いい子はやるもんだと
おかしいと自分で考えるんじゃないんだということでしょう
そこで論争するっていうのは
ただの口で抑えることだと
あの女優というバカが思ってるんですね
その人だけじゃなくて
報道関係の人々もそう思ってるんです
口はむちゃくちゃ喋るのはものすごい論争はうまいんだと
と思ったらみんな負けちゃったね
あんなくだらない もう何の意味もない言葉に逆を考えないんです
ですから どんな論にも何がありますか？反論もあります
そちら両方考えるとかなり自分も元気であるし
もういつでも違う知恵
論と反論の上にある 3番目の知恵が現れる
論は知識 反論も知識 論と反論を合わせたところで
何か違う方向 違うものが生まれてくる
それは知恵なんです これ結構結構いい遊びなんです
反論考えるの 私はこれ
いろんなものを批判みたいなことを言うのは
いつでも論と反論と両方考えているんだから
ですから 僕にとっては何がいいかというと
一つも言えないんです
政治 経済 社会 どんな問題についても
あなたの意見は何ですかと
別の人に意見があるわけじゃない
あなた方の意見を言いなさいと
全部片っ端から破っちゃいます
そちらの全部反論は出せますけど
そこでじゃあどうすればいいかと聞けば
すぐ答えを出してあげる
これですと それいつでもこの正論と反論
みんな自分勝手だから
世の中の人間は自分思っているものを正当化するために
正論するために論理を成り立てるんですね
証拠は でも違う証拠は
それは壊す証拠もそこにあるんです
それは関係なしと ですから
私たちは知恵が欲しいんだったら
正論 反論 両方考えて考えて置いておく
そうすると ちょっと第3番目の答えが出てくる
それに知恵というんです
そこで今日ちょっとテキスト持ってきたんだけど
これで知恵って何ですかって
仏教における知恵を説明しようと
と  77種類かな かなり知恵があるんです
これ全部 1 行ずつ  1 行ずつ
いろんな知恵の分析と作り方と作り方よりは分析だけ
だからこう ちょっとした甘い話じゃないんです
知恵の世界っていうのは
すっごい膨大なんです
仏教では知恵の分析もきちんとあるんです
一般的にはこの大体 名前だけでも 2 ページぐらい殴りますけど
ていさっとてにゃーなーに
セブンティースリー  73
73種類あります それは高度な知恵
仏教の世界でいうと 超エリート知恵
その中で サッタサッティティニャーナニサーカサダーラナニ
77種類の知恵が釈迦尊の弟子たちに得られることはできるんだと
いわゆる悟らなきゃダメですけど
その場合は  77種類 そうすると6残るんですね
6つ その 6つは釈迦尊にだけあって
他の人には得られないんだと
ですから 一般の人々にはちょっと得られない
ものすごい強力なもう知恵もありますけど
でも知恵としてはもう差がいっぱい
もう 77種類  73種類あるというんだけど
ただすぐひらめくというところは同じなんです
僕はこれちょっと目を通してみたんだけど
怖くてもうこれから引用する僕はできないんです
あまりもすごい世界です
で この反論からもうそれ最終的にこれしか言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
これで話は終わりますけど
反論から我々に正しい知恵が生まれる
なぜかというと この世の中では
人間は欲で自分勝手で
自分本位で 自分のために
好き勝手にものを言ったり考えたりするだけ
ありのままのことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
豚肉を食べたいんだから
神様が作ってくれたと言うんですね
それ理由があるわけじゃないんです
ものすごい勝手なんです
で ユダヤ教では海のお魚食べてもいいと
空の飛ぶものは食べてもいいと
この鱗入っていて スネがあるものは食べてもいいと
それからこの そういろいろ言って
でも豚は食べてはいけませんと
なぜならば この足が牛と同じく
でも体はなんとか違うと
なんとか訳が作ってるんですね
ただ 豚肉嫌いでしたでしょうね
もしかすると そこで誰もヒンドゥー教だったら牛は食べないんですね
やはりインドの文化の農業社会だから
もう牛は仕事するんですね
それも食べるようになっちゃったら
もう全部台無しなんですね
ですから 食べない気持ちはわかりますけど
ずっと仕事をしてくれる牛をね
殺して食べるということは
やっぱりできるもんじゃないしね
その代わりに豚はかわいそうに
チキンニワトリはかわいそうですね
ユダヤ教にしたっても
イスラム教にしたっても
やっぱりまあ豚は食べないと置いておくし
で 鶏は食べるし 僕はそれでそれに面白く言うのは
牛食べてはいけないとある人々は言う
豚肉食べたら汚れるとある人々は言うし
誰も鶏には親切じゃないんではないか
じゃあ私は新しい宗教を作ろう
鶏食うなと 誰もがその鶏を助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだから
そういうのは まあ人間の論理っていうのはいい加減なんですね
結局は 日本人はすごく酒が好きなんですね
だから仏教で酒飲むなと言うんだけど
よく言うんですね と言っても
あーだこうだとか それはと言ったっても
別に知識があるわけでもないし
酒は体に悪いっていうことを自分でも知ってるはずでしょうし
ただ飲みたいっていうことだけなんですね
それを正直に認めないで
それに哲学を言う だから僕は怒るんですね
その私は酒飲みたいなんて言ったら
僕はその人に全然微かにも怒らないんです
正直だから 飲みたいよと
それにと言っても 酒はやっぱり適量に体にとるとちゃんと健康的になりんではないかとか
食べ物は美味しくなるんじゃないかとか
神様にそれはもうちゃんとお供えしてるんじゃないかとか
日本の伝統ではないかとか
結婚式でも酒飲むんじゃないかとかね
だからみんな結構むちゃくちゃですから
酒飲んであれでなんとかかわしちゃってます
釈尊正気じゃないんだからね
それより牛乳とかね 水とか
飲んだ方がいいかもしれませんだけど
でさ そういうふうに まあもういろんなことを言えるんでしょ
面白いよ そんなこと言うと
普通だったらなんかね
お酒をもうこうやって入れて
それもう三回飲んで またあの人もまたこうすごく通で
あれ酔っ払っちゃうんだから
あなた方正気じゃないんだから結婚できるわけないよとも言えるし
水を飲めと 水は清らかで基本的で
命の元であって とにかくまあ
そういうなんとかね 原因を理由を言って酒飲みたいと理由をつける
だから そこに正直なところは
まあ私はもう飲みたい
いくら釈尊がやめなさいと言っても
なんか私はやっぱりそれでもやりたいという正直なところは言わない
ですから 世の中の論理っていうのはそんなもんで
全然怖いものはないんです
ですから すぐあの そういう反論の立場ですか
この違う方向も見ていくと
結論としてこれを言える
すべての生命は永遠に生きたいと
死にたくはないんだと
生きていてよかったとか
人生は幸福だと 尊い命だと
我々にはありがたい霊魂
魂 仏心なんかは付いているんだとか言ってるでしょ
宗教の世界やらいろんなところ
それは全部嘘です 証拠はないでしょ
あれ ただ執着 自分の希望
ごまかしてるだけ ですから
智慧が現れたら悟るっていうのはそういうことなんです
すべてはわかってくるんです
他の宗教を語った時から勉強しなくても
何言ってるかと どんな大体ヨーロッパ型のね
外国型の宗教 どんな宗教見たっても
やっぱり永遠な命というのを約束しているんですね
天国で それは人間の希望でですね
それは死にたくないんだから
現れる元なんですね 死にたくないんですけど
死ぬでしょ おかしいのは確実に死ぬなのに
それを認めたくないという
完全に馬鹿馬鹿らしい
完全に完璧に確実に死ぬでしょ
それ認めたくないが故に
巨大な文明 文化 宗教 哲学を作ってるんだから
全部倒れちゃうんです
ちょっと本の柱の上にすごい建物を作ってるんです
事実を見るということで
その全部 この空の上に建てる建物は壊れるんです
ですから このお釈迦様は生きてるものはみんな死にますと
すべては無常ですと 物には実体とか変化しないものは何もないんだと
瞬間瞬間変わっていくんだと
これは私のものやというふうな取るものは何もないし
これは私というものは何もないと
人間 絶対認めたくないことを言ってるんです
でも それは残念ながら事実なんです
ですから 今 幻覚の嘘の世界
人々は認めたい嘘の中にいるいて
そうすると反論を見てみちゃうと
真実の世界は見つかるんです
ですから 智慧の最高なところっていうのは
無常を知ることで 無常を体験することなんです
苦しみ ドッカを体験することなんです
それはすごい超越したレベルなんです
それの瞬間にすべてをわかって
すべての物事を理解して
すべてに対する執着を捨てて解脱っていうものを体験する
ですから この方法でいけば
普通の生き方は楽しくなっちゃうし
ストレスは消えちゃうし
健康的になるし 智慧がどんどん発展していって
解脱も体験することができます
ということで終了します
ありがとうございます